union boss thinks it was a mistake for
president biden to cancel the keystone
xl
pipeline project afl-cio president
richard trumka
not happy with how biden went about it
listen
i wish you hadn't done that on the first
day because
the laborers international was right it
did and will cost
us jobs in the process i wish he had
paired that more carefully
with the the thing that he did second by
saying
here's where we're creating jobs we can
do mine reclamation we can fix leaks and
we can fix seeps
and create hundreds of thousands of jobs
in doing all of that stuff
you know greg peter ducey was basically
mocked in the white house
briefing room about this today he asked
jen saki
you know can you please tell us where
are these thousands of laid off workers
going to go
for their green job to which she
mockingly responded i'd certainly
welcome you to present your data of
all those thousands of thousands of
people who won't be getting a green job
maybe next time you're here you can
present that to us
that's really not a funny issue there's
a lot of the family
families affected by this but i mean it
goes back to what geraldo said in the
previous segment that there is this kind
of
um mixture of superiority and sanctimony
that allows progressives
to kind of like drip on you and it's
just kind of like what kerry does
when he or um kamala harris says you
know they could
learn to remove land mines or you know
they could learn to solar
go to china uh you know it's like it's
that kind of id they
really do not they think of a but they
don't think of
b in order to get to c they have no
second step
other than to destroy something nothing
about the pipeline
made anybody's killing the pipeline that
didn't make anybody's lives better
it didn't help people during the
pandemic it didn't have it won't have
any effect on the climate
it will remain right it's a sad truth
that america may have elected the
manchurian candidate which is what the
media was saying about trump and russia
but it's actually biden in the hard
progressive right
and jesse to toraldo's point about what
we
don't see when we live out here on the
coast is happening in ohio
you take pennsylvania for example that's
where trumka was taking issue
he said you destroy a hundred jobs in
greene county pennsylvania where he grew
up
create a hundred jobs in california that
doesn't do those 100 families very much
good they don't want to move
yeah let's say i'm laying down pipeline
in pennsylvania and then i get laid off
by joe biden
if i were to build solar panels
somewhere what happens if the next solar
panel manufacturer is in massachusetts
i'm going to have to drive seven hours
to massachusetts
to build a solar panel at a firm that
probably isn't even hiring
it's just not practical i think what
you're going to see long-term
unions moving away from the democratic
party into the republican camp
and you're already seeing gas prices up
they're up 30 cents
per gallon at the pump since joe's come
into yeah and january was the biggest
month ever i think in 30 years for oil
so life is about to get a lot more
expensive in the united states
for a lot of people and joe's going to
get politically hurt by it erica my wife
and i have a little radio show in the
mornings here in cleveland
and we had this debate and she said but
you're a grandfather don't you want a
clean
atmosphere a clean environment of course
i do i answered but
uh you know you could you stop a
pipeline midway
how does that help anybody you know
you've got to transition you got to
evolve and i think that's what's missing
katie
well keystone may have been one of many
pipelines that the white house decides
to pull the permits
for they're open to looking at other
pipelines and they keep telling people
we'll just go build solar panel
solar panels when those jobs aren't
available and the majority of the
companies that build them
are based in china all right we will
leave it there one